if we ask ourselves what reasons do we
have to believe in a soul with my staff
I ask you do we have to believe is quite
the orientation to the cat's in many
ways the American Revolution wasn't just
a war the war was actually only a minor
part of the American Revolution the
Romans structured a man-made worldwide
Empire out of architectural forms and
exerted a lasting influence on the
architecture and the architects of post
classical times great literature poetry
painting music they show what human
beings can be the capacity of the human
spirit I think you can come up with good
through Christian theological readings
of the New Testament and you can come up
with very decent mr. offer reading the
New Testament they just always won't be
the same kind of lead this means that
not only does the Tree of Life connect
you to all the living things on the
planet but the origin of life
connections to the entire universe
that's a deep thought all these things
but reading these novels is not just
reading about those things it's also
going to be the process of watching an
artistic form unfold the characteristic
comment on making a real discovery is
not Eureka its pomp that's why
you